how you been Dennis just the young kid
with a dream yourself better for talking
to you better for talking with you right
now the red circle sports again is
available every single Tuesday at
podcast one sports.com in the podcast
one app what's on your mind sports watch
Dennis what's been leaping out here to
talk about on your pod well the great
the the the greatest of all tournaments
about to begin
tonight the Stanley Cup and I think it's
for the next ironically it's two months
during your loins gird your loins Dennis
there don't write venture one leaf and I
think Verne Troyer's coming in on the
master-blaster shoulders but every game
is a you know what I mean I can't watch
the NFL anymore last time we spoke
really
have you really sworn off the NFL I
watched the I don't think I watch the
Super Bowl but I watched some of the
playoff games because I can't I'd say I
watched ten percent of what I used to
watch I I finally got it they kept
saying it was unsafe game Goodell said
there were problems with the game
Goodell said that there was no social
justice I it finally sunk in I said I'm
participating in an activity I shouldn't
be I got it it's ironic it comes from
the guys getting 40 million a year out
of it but I finally sank in he said no
no they they don't want to play
Thursday's but I you know is such a
typical thing where he said I've got
actuary tables and say there's no
discernible difference than all the
players say we don't want to play
Thursday's we feel it's dangerous and he
said well I'm gonna continue to play on
Thursdays because I care so much and I
just thought okay I get it
they don't they don't really care
they're gonna make the helmets more
kubrick in and the playing fields more
adherent and the you know sleep few
balls now bouncing around out there so I
get it yeah I finally it's sunk in I
thought Goodell is right this is not
something you should either have kids
play or watch so I'm out hmm so but you
did watch some what Steeler playoff
games is that what you want hmm I
watched I like Brady a lot
but I don't know this dealers as well as
I used to you know because I haven't
lived there in so many years right and I
don't have the NFL package anymore so
that's been two years now I quit that
and I didn't periodically I'll listen
Albee no because I've talked to him he
says he's got a good one you know so
we'll talk during the week and I'll
watch him I love listening down the best
at it yes yeah but I listen to it more
for situational things that just sound
exciting in the same way that like I've
gone to Wrestlemania or I watch it you
know other things but as far as sports
ago it has made me go back to baseball
the the atrophy of the NFL and the
hockey is my fav so the hockey tonight
so again I know it's been a while since
you've lived in Pittsburgh but the
Penguins is that is that your your
interest in the in the Stanley Cup the
fact they won back-to-back they drop
puck tonight against Philadelphia yeah I
love the Penguins and you know I follow
the Kings because they live out here but
and I will say this about Murray I know
he had a concussion for Pittsburgh but I
also sense that sometimes you watch
these lean stringbean kids in goal and
like Dryden when he came up that one
year all of a sudden they they lock into
some sort of God amongst men guys but he
is a kid you know yeah I still see
Murray having like acting when they do
interviews with him and he lost his old
man early in the air and I guess it's
room for a complete loop so obviously
when you're in that blue paint you have
to be and I'm sure between that man's
concussion it's just been a bit of a
traumatic year now there comes a point I
believe in each of these NHL games since
nobody gives an angstrom and they just
press press press it's like water
bearing on a surface we'll see if Murray
is healed up or is maybe what it's want
for a young man to do that he's just not
quite there this year that he hasn't
reinforced all the rebar but if he's on
if Murray plays out of his mind again
certainly they have a shot at the third
one they've got Sidney and Malcolm tube
are you Lee to the five greatest players
on the planet and then the Kings are
dropping puck tonight facing off with
with the number one seed Las Vegas I
mean that's a big thing what a story
that's this year
yeah they've been great and I think that
their last 18 games I thought I heard
some statistic I don't know if you ever
listening and HL network God that is
some really beautiful puck being talked
over there but kind of you know they've
kind of in their last come back to earth
a little and the Kings are strong up the
middle man it's like baseball Ricci when
you got dowdy
quickie and Kopitar up the middle and
brown looks like he's been freed up I
don't know what the interaction was
between Dustin Brown and coach Sutter
but obviously brownies a new man new
lease on life penguin or the Kings gave
up the lease goals in any major sport
when you go to win the you know the
championship to be the best defensive
team certainly harder as well and I
think it'll be a seven game series but I
certainly that's one more I'd give the
Kings a good shot Dennis Miller host of
red circle sports available on podcast
one new episodes and new pods drop every
single Tuesday right here on the Rich
Eisen show and so what about baseball
has attracted you Dennis what's going on
there
the fact that by the way rich I want to
say I did my sources tell me yes on the
ground that they find out what goes in
on inside the King Faisal tent that is
the concussion protocol now I actually
is wondering why do I see guys go in
there like some Stargate skg or
something where they're cavorted into
another dimension I've never seen I may
come back in I found out what the NFL
protocol is around for whether or not
they asked the kid inside there what's
currently constitutes a catch in the leg
[Music]
[Applause]
that you you know again I know you're
you've you've turned away you've shunned
or you've said that the sport has
shunned you however you want to put it
no they simplified it they simplified it
in the last couple weeks they fixed it
they I'm sure it'll be good
they make like this games not
complicated at all anymore now you know
I always think that with Trump he was
doing away with five what was he trying
to get rid of you had to lose two
regulations for one end when ever hear
about the competition getting big and by
the way I think Jim I think Jeff Fischer
was the big guy in the competition
wasn't he for the last you know not
anymore obviously
well I'd fish at one point you know and
when they just come up short down at the
you know there's a goal line he's in the
game but he was he was founded and then
on a rotary phone towards the end and
every year they would go into that
competition committee and figure out you
know that hockey Lee didn't even lift
weights all that was just from signaling
penalties you know his upper body
development and my feeling is they
should go in there one year and say
we've got so many damn rules it's silly
we're gonna prune back ten I think the
fans would like that but right now it
used to be a game the people want to to
escape on weekends and now it reminds
him in the office and I think that's I
think there's a bad thing I think god
that's all the BS I have to face in the
office every day filling out forms in
triplicate anyway back to baseball what
fascinates me is Terry Collins was a
good man but a points out the the nature
of sports is that you can be a
completely grand fellow
and not be fitted for a job due to the
Peter Principle in any given moment I
look at Callaway he comes in hungry
knows how to run the pad I look at
Collins he seemed like the nicest man I
bumped into him once and you know I'm
talking about the Mets because they're
out of the box at nine and one and there
might I son the favorite team and you
know you get rid of the I don't know who
was their trainer last year I think it
was Blanche DuBois they were so delicate
you get some stretching exercise in
there and you get a young guy who feels
a little more vibrant and look at it
turns around nine and one so it reminded
me that there can be men who are helming
teams who are exemplary gentlemen and
are never going to win Andy Reid seems
to me to be a fine enough fellow I met
him I know he said some personal grief I
think he's one of the best
regular-season coaches you've ever saw
but something about they get a hits in
there
getting up when they're in the kill zone
you know and my feeling is you've got a
really swing wild you know from the
heels when that's one thing you got to
give the Peterson eye a in the Super
Bowl last year is that when I saw the
replay that I don't know what it was
triple reverse yeah before I thought my
man realizes he's better he better go
for this oh yeah then that's that's
that's why they won that game because he
had the stones to well first of all
Foles was the one who said let's try it
then he looked at his quarterback right
in the eyes and realized what the
quarterback was suggesting he said yeah
let's do it instead of settling for
threes is the way that you got a beat
Belichick what was your late but couple
more minutes left with Dennis Miller
again red circle sports available on
podcast one certainly every Tuesday what
was your relationship like with
Belichick when you were doing on the
attack you know I could tell the
Belichick never wanted to open his mouth
because then he'd have to keep opening
his mouth listen you're sitting in a
room with 15 guys who are there for the
Freak hot dogs
I've got quarter jackets on with those
things on you know the elbow pads
they're pissed off that they've topped
out at like 40k summer they're doing
stringer work imagine you're a stringer
covering and then I file team you're
right at the gate of watching all the
riches and your boss tells you he's
gonna pay you by the column inch in
other words he's working out a slide
rule for to give you your salary so you
got a bunch of cranky guys in there
Belichick doesn't like them I don't
think they know football that well
there's a couple guys up there in Boston
who did I forget that one guys named
Shaughnessy or something but the the
damn something that's Jonesy you sure
yeah I think there's some smart guys up
there by and large you're feeling
questions and Belichick you can see him
thinking I just don't want to open this
Pandora's box where I act interested in
this guy so he goes flat face
yeah and I'm good for him but when he
was in a room with albedo and 5c and
granite not me at first I could see him
looking askew at me but after I met when
I was you know a couple times I find him
gregarious funny super smart he's the
best coach in the history of the NFL
right yes
he's they might you know urban says they
should rename it the Belichick trophy
one day I told him please ask that of
Belichick in a press conference please
do that once
at the superevil reactor just fantastic
that would be a famous eye roll i would
be remissed before I let you go Dennis
it Mitzi shore passed away here in Los
Angeles the common sit again when do
they happen that happened this morning
uh long life man I gotta admit see all I
remember this about bitsy and rest her
soul and Comedy Store right here in Los
Angeles
yes and I like her son Polly he's always
been kind to me and Mitzi put me up a
few times but I do remember meeting with
bitsy after my first set there I may
said Mitzi wants to meet you and there's
only some table in the back or reminding
me Burt Reynolds in Boogie Nights
remember when he goes out into the deep
valley catch some act and he's way in
that bag table there's always that table
where the fix is a six and I went back
in Mitzi was sitting there and she said
Dennis I think you have a funny mind but
I don't think you're a performer and if
you continue to do so you should wear
more sweaters and I remember writing
that dot and it didn't invert Lee helps
you because when when you are suffering
and up against it in comedy and you
think well I the note I got from the
expert was where more sweaters you
become your own expert you know I mean
you're able to look at that I wrote it
down on a post as well who you know I
don't know much but I think I'll act as
my own tour guide here if the if the
note I'm getting from the top where are
more sweaters hey Dennis thanks for the
call and appreciate it and joy being on
red circle sports when you when you when
you boot it it rebooted it for podcast
one sports calm and the app podcast one
please come back and let's chat brother
right back at you that's Dennis Miller
at Dennis DMZ the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience